we've talked quite a bit about the
vaccine but there's an incredible new
technology that pfizer is developing
with the paxlovid antiviral for covid
where does that stand
how does that work
and how are you able to develop it in
four months
like you said and all of that in just a
few minutes
first of all what this is about this is
a real game changer
this is a course of treatment that you
get only if you get the disease you get
covered
then what happens is that you will take
for five days pills day and night
and twice a day for five days and
instead of ten people from those that
the easiest to go to hospital
only one will go
this is an end
with all the caveats that the numbers
are small no one died it was a hundred
percent efficacy on deaths of course i'm
sure that
in
real world when the numbers are getting
very high we may have
99 instead of 100 but
these are spectacular
results for something that you can take
home and stay home
the biggest problem right now in europe
in the us when we have surges every time
that we have a search
of
of covet it is that the icus are full
the hospitals are paralyzed they have to
postpone
electric surgeries they have to postpone
other operations because they don't have
the capacity because of that keeping
people out
of the hospitals home keeping people
[Music]
without dying
it is something they didn't have before
and this is a significant significant
game changer
you